livraison de colis par vélo cargo
désengorger le centre-ville et réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre un
projet pilote d'un an qui réunit quatre
compagnies de transport à vélo et
seulement un joueur de la livraison par
camion plus haut les deux on voulait
absolument envoyer un message clair à
différents opérateurs à différents
compagnie de dire wahou pur business et
nous on veut innover alors travaillons
ensemble
l'ancienne gare d'autobus situé sur la
rue berri est laissé à l'abandon a été
racheté par la ville l'an dernier au
coût de 18 millions de dollars elle
servira de centre de transbordement
je vous dirais que prend crac mans
actuellement nous avons un des véhicules
qui rendent à environ à 60 clients par
jour
un départ modeste faut savoir que
l'amérique du nord on est assez en
retard dans ce que la recherche de
solutions pour la livraison du dernier
kilomètre en grande partie dû à la
manière dont les villes se sont
développés en europe ça fait déjà
longtemps que s'attaquent à ce problème
là paris londres berlin
c'est le secteur privé qui offre des
livraisons à zéro émission par camion ou
en vélo en allemagne ça fait déjà bien
longtemps des hached est une entreprise
allemande qui la plus grande au monde où
elle mène déjà implanté dans la plupart
des 10 villes allemandes des centres de
transports demande locale
à montréal c'est près d'une cinquantaine
de vélos cargo pouvant recevoir jusqu'à
400 livres de chargement qui
sillonneront les rues du centre ville
nous c'est surtout de démontrer qu'on
les la clientèle existe sur l'île de
montréal pour de la livraison écologique
durable en vélo cargo est aussi en v en
camion électrique
la ville négocie toujours avec d'autres
entreprises de livraison pour qu'elles
participent au projet l'objectif est de
créer des centres de transbordement
partout sur l'île de montréal
ici marie josée paquet comme radio
canada montréal